الثالث من يناير عام 2020 الليله التي قتل
فيها قائد فيلق القدس في الحرس الثوري
قاسم سليماني بغاره جويه امريكيه في
العراق قتل فيها ايضا ابو مهدي المهندس
الرجل الثاني بمليشيا الحشد الشعبي ولم
يتبقى لهما من اثر سوى بقايا حطام سيارتين
كان يستقلانها برفقه قياده اخرى وهذا
التمثال بالقرب من مطار بغداد الدولي
وفي ذكرى مقتلهما الثالثه اقامت حركه حماس
في قطاع غزه حفله تابين على شواطئها رافعه
علم البلدين حركه حماس احيه هذه الذكرى
بتنظيم مهرجان خطابي في غزه تحت رعايه
اللجنه الفلسطينيه ليوم القدس العالميه
شارك فيه ممثلون عن الفصائل والقوه
الوطنيه والاسلاميه ونواب من المجلس
التشريعي
ينتقل اليوم في الذكرى السنويه الثالثه
لاستشهاد قائد فيلق القدس في الحرس الثوري
للجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران
وشهيد القدس
القائد الراحل قاسم سليماني
والشهيد القائد ابو مهدي المهندس وفي
غالبيه شوارع غزه تجدهم وضعوا لافتات كتب
عليها اصدقاء فلسطين ودعموها اصدقاءنا
واعداؤها اعدائنا كانت سياستنا وستبقى في
الوقت الذي تلسع فيه النيران صور سليمان
في ايران غضبا تقيموا حماس ذكرى رحيله
ذكرى اراد ان يتخلص منها الشعب الايراني
اما حماس فقررت ترسيخها رغم ان للشعب
الفلسطيني رايا اخر يشبه ذاك السخط الذي
اختلج في قلوب الايرانيين المتظاهرين
الذين اجتمعوا على وصف سليمان
بمجرم القرن